there was a yougov poll in 2017 that
showed 60 percent of Democrats believed
that Russia actually tampered with
voting tallies in the 2016 election now
no one in the media ever actually said
that that happened but they just
repeatedly said Trump Russia possible
collusion
and it got to the point where this had
been repeated so many times your average
person just took for granted that it
happened
and then they went to the most extreme
version of what they were hearing
because of course no one in media was
willing to clarify that that wasn't what
was happening so even though they didn't
say anything openly dishonest at least
the ones who didn't know that there was
literally nothing to the allegations of
collusion they were convincing people to
believe something which was totally
factually inaccurate